Les avancées qui se sont produites en astronomie,
cosmologie, et biologie, ces dix dernières années,
sont vraiment extraordinaires --
au point où nous en savons plus sur notre univers et comment il fonctionne
que vous ne pouvez l'imaginer.
Mais il y a quelque chose d'autre que j'ai relevé
alors que ces changements survenaient, alors que les gens commençaient à comprendre que
hum... oui, il y a vraiment un trou noir au centre de chaque galaxie.
Les écrivains scientifiques et les éditeurs -- je ne devrais pas dire écrivains scientifiques,
je devrais dire les gens qui écrivent sur la science
-- et les éditeurs s'assoiraient autour d'un verre de bière,
après une dure journée de travail, et parleraient de
ces incroyables perceptions du fonctionnement de l'univers.
Et inévitablement, cela finirait par ce que je pensais être très étrange,
les façons dont le monde pourrait soudainement finir.
Et c'est de ça que je veux parler aujourd'hui. (Rires)
Ah, vous riez, pauvres fous. (Rires)
Voix dans le public : est-ce qu'on peut partir un peu plus tôt ?
(Rires) Ouais, nous avons besoin de temps !
Au début, cela me semblait un peu fantaisiste, mais après avoir réfléchi sur beaucoup de ces idées,
j'ai commencé à en prendre au sérieux. Et c'est alors que le 11 septembre est arrivé,
et j'ai pensé, ah, mon Dieu,
je ne peux pas aller à la conférence TED et parler de la fin du monde.
Personne ne veut entendre ça. Pas après ça !
Et ça m'a conduit à discuter avec d'autres gens, d'autres scientifiques,
parfois sur d'autres sujets, et une des personnes auxquelles j'ai parlé
qui était neuroscientifique, a dit,
tu sais, je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de solutions aux problèmes que tu soulèves,
et ça me rappelle la conférence de Michael d'hier
et sa mère qui disait qu'on ne peut pas trouver de solution si on n'a pas de problème.
Donc nous sommes partis à la recherche de solutions aux différentes possibilités de fin du monde
et miracle, nous les avons trouvées.
Ce qui m'amène à une vidéo du président Bush
en conférence de presse il y a 2 semaines.
Peut-on l'envoyer, Andrew ?
Président Bush : "Quelque soit le prix de notre sécurité,
et quelque soit le prix de notre liberté, nous devons le payer."
Je suis d'accord avec le président.
Il veut deux mille milliards de dollars pour nous protéger du terrorisme l'année prochaine,
un budget fédéral de deux mille milliards de dollars qui nous renvoie rapidement à des déficits budgétaires
-- mais les terroristes ne sont pas la seule menace.
Il y a de très sérieux désastres qui nous attendent
et que nous négligeons comme nous l'avons fait
pour le terrorisme et pour les événements du 11 septembre.
Je proposerais donc que si nous prenons 10 milliards de dollars
de ces 2 mille milliards de budget
-- ce qui ne représente que 2% de ce budget
-- et que l'on attribue un milliard de dollars à chacun des problèmes
dont je vais vous parler -- la grande majorité pourrait être résolue,
et on pourrait s'accommoder du reste. Donc j'espère que vous trouverez ça fascinant --
je suis fasciné par ce genre de chose, je dois l'admettre --
pour moi, ce sont -- les blattes de Keith Richards.
Mais j'espère aussi -- parce que je pense que les personnes dans cette salle peuvent vraiment changer le monde
-- j'espère que vous emporterez quelques-unes de ces choses avec vous,
et quand vous aurez l'opportunité d'avoir de l'influence,
que vous essaierez de faire dépenser de l'argent sur quelques-unes de ces idées.
Commençons. Numéro 10 : nous perdons le désir de survivre.
Nous vivons l'âge d'une médecine moderne incroyable ;
nous sommes tous en meilleure santé qu'il y a 20 ans.
les gens ont accès à des meilleurs soins --
mais mentalement, c'est l'effondrement.
l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé estime qu'aujourd'hui
une personne sur cinq est cliniquement déprimée.
et l'OMS dit aussi que la dépression est
la plus grosse épidémie que l'humanité n'ait jamais rencontrée.
Bientôt, les découvertes génétiques et de meilleurs médicaments
vont nous permettre de penser que 100 ans est une durée de vie normale.
Une petite fille qui naîtra demain en moyenne -- médiane -- vivra 83 ans.
Notre longévité augmente de presque une année par an.
Le problème avec le vieillissement
est que les gens de plus de 65 ans sont ceux qui se suicident le plus.
Quelles sont donc les solutions ?
Nous n'avons pas vraiment d'assurance sur la santé mentale dans ce pays,
et c'est -- (Applaudissements) -- c'est un crime.
Quelque chose comme 98% des gens déprimés --
et je veux dire en dépression sévère
-- j'ai un ami avec une très sévère dépression
-- c'est un mal qu'on peut soigner, avec les médicaments et la technologie actuels.
Mais c'est souvent une combinaison de psychothérapie et de pilules.
Les pilules seules ne font rien, surtout pour la dépression clinique.
Vous devriez pouvoir aller chez un psychiatre ou un psychologue
et payer votre ticket modérateur de 10 dollars, et être traité,
tout comme on le fait quand on s'est coupé le bras. C'est ridicule.
Deuxièmement, les firmes pharmaceutiques ne développerons pas des médicaments
psychotropes sophistiqués. Nous savons que la plupart des maladies mentales ont une composante
biologique que l'on peut gérer.
Et nous en savons beaucoup plus sur le cerveau aujourd'hui
qu'il y a dix ans. Nous avons besoin d'aides du gouvernement fédéral,
via les National Institutes of Health (NIH) et la National Science Foundation (NSF)
et d'autres instituts comme ça pour commencer à aider les firmes pharmaceutiques
à développer des médicaments psychotropes avancés.
Continuons. Numéro 9 -- ne riez pas -- les aliens envahissent la Terre.
Il y a 10 ans, vous ne trouviez pas un seul astronome --
ou, très peu -- dans le monde qui vous aurait dit
qu'il y a des planètes hors du système solaire.
En 1995, on en a trouvé trois, aujourd'hui on en est à 80.
On en trouve deux ou trois par mois.
Toutes celles que l'on a trouvées, au fait, se trouve dans le même petit coin que nous,
la Voie Lactée. Il doit y avoir des millions de planètes dans la Voie Lactée,
et comme Carl Sagan l'a rabâché pendant des années,
et a été moqué à cause de ça, il doit y en avoir des milliards de milliards dans l'Univers.
Dans quelques années, la NASA va envoyer quatre ou cinq télescopes vers Jupiter,
où il y a moins de poussières, afin de rechercher des planètes semblables à la Terre,
qu'on ne peut ni voir avec la technologie actuelle, ni détecter.
Ça devient évident que les chances que la vie n'existe pas autre part dans l'Univers,
et probablement proche de nous, est une idée plutôt improbable.
Et les chances que certains ne soient pas plus intelligents que nous est tout aussi improbable.
Souvenez-vous, nous sommes une civilisation avancée --
une civilisation industrielle, si vous voulez -- depuis seulement 200 ans,
même si chaque fois que je vais à Pompéi, je suis étonné qu'ils aient eu
l'équivalent d'un MacDonald's à chaque coin de rue.
Je ne sais pas comment la civilisation a réellement avancé depuis l'an 79,
mais il y a une grosse probabilité -- je le pense vraiment,
et je ne crois pas aux aliens, mais -- et je ne crois pas qu'il y a des aliens sur Terre
ou autre chose de ce genre. Mais il y a des chances que nous croisions
une civilisation plus intelligente que la nôtre.
Maintenant, que se passera-t-il ? S'ils viennent pour, vous savez,
pomper nos océans pour l'hydrogène ?
Et nous écraser comme des mouches, de la même façon que nous éliminons les mouches quand nous allons
dans la forêt vierge pour la déforester.
Regardons notre propre histoire -- le physicien défunt Gerard O'Neill a dit,
"Les civilisations avancées d'Occident ont eu un effet destructif
sur toutes les civilisations primitives avec lesquelles ils ont eu des contacts,
même quand ils ont essayé
de protéger et préserver la civilisation primitive."
Si des aliens viennent nous rendre visite, nous sommes la civilisation primitive.
Donc, quelle est la solution ? (Rires)
Dieu merci, vous pouvez tous lire !
Ça peut sembler ridicule, mais nous avons une piteuse histoire d'anticipation de choses comme celles-ci
et nous ne sommes pas vraiment préparés pour elles.
Combien d'énergie et d'argent faut-il pour avoir un réel plan
pour négocier avec une espèce avancée ?
Deuxièmement, et vous allez m'entendre davantage en parler --
nous devons devenir une nation d'avant-garde dans les voyages spatiaux.
Nous devons développer
l'idée que la Terre ne durera pas éternellement,
notre Soleil ne durera pas éternellement --
si nous voulons que la race humaine dure éternellement, nous devons coloniser la Voie Lactée.
Et ce n'est pas quelque chose d'incompréhensible, aujourd'hui.
(Applaudissements)
Ça nous aidera beaucoup si nous rencontrons une civilisation avancée en cours de route,
si nous essayons de devenir une civilisation avancée. Numéro 8 --
Voix dans le public : Steve, c'est ce que je vais faire après TED. (Rires et Applaudissements)
Vous l'avez ! Vous avez le job.
Numéro 8 : l'effondrement de l'écosystème.
En juillet dernier, dans "Science", le journal "Science",
19 océanographes ont publié un article très, très inhabituel --
ce n'était pas vraiment un rapport de recherche, c'était un discours.
Ils disaient, "nous avons observé les océans depuis longtemps,
nous voulons vous dire qu'ils ne sont pas en danger, ils sont sur le point de s'effondrer."
Beaucoup d'autres écosystèmes sur Terre sont en vrai danger.
Nous vivons un époque d'extinctions massives qui dépasse le record des fossiles
d'un facteur de 10 000.
Nous avons perdu 25% des espèces uniques à Hawaï ces 20 dernières années,
la Californie devrait perdre 25% de ses espèces les 40 prochaines années.
Quelque part dans la forêt Amazonienne se trouve un arbre marginal.
Vous coupez cet arbre, et l'écosystème de la forêt vierge s'effondre.
Il y a vraiment un arbre comme ça là-bas. Et c'est ce qui va arriver.
Et quand cet écosystème s'effondrera, il pourrait emporter un écosystème majeur avec lui,
comme notre atmosphère. Que fait-on avec ça ? Quelles sont les solutions ?
Il y a quelques modélisations d'écosystèmes qui arrivent.
Le problème avec les écosystèmes est que nous les comprenons si mal,
que nous ne savons pas qu'ils sont en danger, jusqu'à ce qu'il soit trop tard.
Nous devons savoir plus tôt qu'ils sont en danger,
et nous devons être capable d'injecter les solutions possibles dans des modèles.
Et avec les ressources informatiques à notre disposition aujourd'hui
-- il y a, comme je le dis, des initiatives en cours, mais il faut de l'argent.
La National Science Foundation a besoin de -- vous savez,
presque tout l'argent qui est dépensé dans ce pays, pour la science,
provient du gouvernement fédéral, d'une façon ou d'une autre.
Et ils doivent donner des priorités, vous savez.
Il y a des gens à la National Science Foundation
qui disent que c'est la chose la plus importante.
C'est une des choses sur lesquelles ils devraient se concentrer.
Deuxièmement, nous devons créer d'énormes réserves de biodiversité sur la planète
et commencer à les déplacer.
Il y a eu une expérience ces quatre ou cinq dernières années à Georges Bank --
ou Grand Banks à Terre Neuve. C'est une zone de non-pêche.
On ne peut pas y pêcher dans un rayon de 320 km.
Et une choses étonnante est arrivée -- presque tous les poissons sont revenus,
et ils se sont reproduits comme des fous. Nous devons commencer à faire ça
tout autour du globe. Nous devons avoir des zones de non-pêche.
Nous devrons dire plus de déforestation en Amazonie pendant 20 ans.
Laissons-la se régénérer, avant de recommencer.
(Applaudissements)
Numéro 7 : incident sur un accélérateur de particules.
Vous vous souvenez de Ted Kaczynski, le Unabomber ?
Une des choses sur lesquelles il radotait était qu'une expérience d'accélérateur de particules
pouvait échapper à tout contrôle et provoquer une réaction en chaîne qui détruirait le monde.
Beaucoup de physiciens rationnels, croyez-le ou pas,
ont eu la même pensée.
Ce printemps, il y a un collisionneur à Brookhaven, à Long Island --
ce printemps il va y avoir une expérience au cours de laquelle ils vont créer des trous noirs.
Ils s'attendent à créer de tout petits trous noirs.
Ils espèrent qu'ils vont disparaitre. (Rires)
J'espère qu'ils ont raison. (Rires)
D'autres expériences de collision -- il y en a une l'été prochain
au CERN -- ont la possibilité de créer quelque chose nommé strangelets,
une sorte d'antimatière qui détruit la matière qu'elle frappe,
et la fait disparaitre. La plupart des physiciens disent que les accélérateurs que nous avons aujourd'hui
ne sont pas assez puissants pour créer des trous noirs et des strangelets
dont nous devons nous soucier, et ils ont probablement raison.
Mais -- tout autour du monde, au Japon, au Canada --
il y a des discussions à ce sujet -- de le relancer aux États-Unis.
Nous en avons fermé un qui devenait énorme.
Mais il y a des discussions pour créer de très gros accélérateurs.
Que pouvons-nous faire ? Quelles sont les solutions ?
C'est l'histoire du renard qui surveille le poulailler, là.
Nous devons -- nous avons besoin des conseils des physiciens des particules pour parler de la physique des particules
et ce qui devrait être fait en physique des particules,
mais nous avons besoin de réflexions et de surveillance externes
sur ce qui se passe avec ces expériences.
Deuxièmement, nous avons un laboratoire naturel autour de la Terre.
Nous avons un champ électromagnétique autour de la Terre,
et il est constamment bombardé de particules à haute énergie, comme les protons.
Et nous ne -- à mon avis -- nous ne passons pas assez de temps
à regarder ce laboratoire naturel et à nous demander d'abord ce qui est sans danger sur Terre.
Numéro 6 : un désastre biotechnologique
C'est un de mes favoris, car on a fait plusieurs articles avec le maïs transgénique.
Ce maïs crée son propre pesticide pour tuer les pyrales.
Vous en avez peut être entendu parlé -- le Starling,
surtout quand tous ces tacos ont été retirés des supermarchés
il y a environ un an et demi.
Ce truc était censé être utilisé uniquement pour la nourriture animale aux États-Unis,
et c'est apparu dans la nourriture humaine, et quelqu'un aurait dû se rendre compte
que ça entrerait dans la nourriture humaine très facilement.
Mais la chose alarmante est qu'il y a quelques mois, au Mexique,
où le maïs transgénique et tout maïs génétiquement modifié est totalement illégal,
ils ont trouvé des gènes de ce maïs dans des plants sauvages.
Nous pensons qu'il est désormais intégré au maïs, au Mexique.
C'est la réserve de la biodiversité génétique du maïs.
Cela nous ramène un scepticisme qui avait disparu,
que les super-graines et les super-maladies peuvent se répandre de part le monde
à cause des biotechnologies, qu'elles pourraient littéralement détruire les réserves de nourriture mondiales
en très peu de temps.
Que faisons-nous pour ça ?
Nous traitons la biotechnologie avec le même soin que pour les centrales nucléaires.
C'est aussi simple. C'est un domaine étonnamment non régulé.
Quand le désastre Starling s'est présenté, il y a eu une bataille entre
l'EPA et la FDA sur qui avait le pouvoir, et sur quelle partie,
et ils n'ont pas réglé ce différend avant des mois. C'est dingue.
Numéro 5, un de mes préférés : le renversement du champ magnétique terrestre.
Croyez-le ou non, ça arrive toutes les quelques centaines de milliers d'années,
et c'est arrivé plusieurs fois dans l'histoire --
le Pôle Nord va au Sud et le Pôle Sud va au Nord, et vice versa.
Mais ce qu'il se passe, quand ce phénomène se produit,
est que nous perdons le champ magnétique terrestre pendant une centaine d'années,
ce qui signifie que tous ces rayons et particules cosmiques
qui nous bombardent depuis le soleil,
et qui sont stoppés par ce champ -- pour faire simple, on va cuire. (Rires)
Voix dans le public : Steve, j'ai des chapeaux en trop ici.
Donc que peut-on faire ? Oh, au fait, nous sommes en retard --
ça s'est produit il y a 780 000 ans.
Donc -- ça aurait dû se reproduire il y a environ 480 000 ans.
Oh, et voici une autre chose
-- des scientifiques pensent maintenant que notre champ magnétique pourrait être affaibli de 5%
Donc on est peut-être à l'aube de ça.
Un des problèmes pour se rendre compte de la santé de la Terre,
est que nous avons -- vous savez, nous n'avons pas de bonnes données météorologiques de plus de 60 ans,
et encore moins de données sur des choses comme la couche d'ozone.
Donc il y a une solution relativement simple.
Il va y avoir beaucoup de lancements de fusées bon marché qui vont arriver
dans six ou sept ans,
qui vont nous emmener en basse atmosphère pour pas cher.
Vous savez, on peut faire de l'ozone avec des pots d'échappement de voiture.
Ce n'est pas difficile -- ce ne sont que trois atomes d'oxygène.
Si on amenait toute la couche d'ozone sur la surface de la Terre,
elle aurait l'épaisseur de deux centimes, à raison de 6 kilos au centimètre carré.
On n'a pas besoin d'autant là-haut.
On doit apprendre comment réparer et regarnir la couche d'ozone.
(Applaudissements)
Numéro 4 : les éruptions solaires géantes.
Les éruptions solaires sont d'énormes explosions magnétiques du Soleil
qui bombardent la Terre avec des particules subatomiques à haute vitesse.
Jusqu'à maintenant, notre atmosphère et notre champ magnétique
nous ont bien protégés.
Occasionnellement, on a des éruptions solaires qui provoquent le chaos
dans les communications et l'électricité.
Mais la chose alarmante est que des astronomes ont étudié récemment
des étoiles similaires à notre Soleil,
et ils ont trouvé que certaines d'entre elles, quand elles atteignent l'âge de notre Soleil,
brillent 20 fois plus. Ne durent pas très longtemps.
Et ils pensent que ce sont de super-éruptions, des millions de fois plus puissantes
que les éruptions que nous avons connues jusqu'alors.
Évidemment, nous ne voulons pas l'une d'elles. (Rires)
Il y a un revers à cela -- en étudiant des étoiles
comme notre Soleil, nous avons trouvé qu'elles traversent des périodes de diminution,
quand l'énergie totale expulsée
diminue de, disons 1%.
1% ne semble pas beaucoup, mais ca pourrait provoquer un âge de glace d'enfer ici.
Donc que pouvons-nous faire ?
(Rires) Commencer à terraformer Mars. C'est un de mes sujets favoris,
j'ai écrit un article là-dessus dans le magazine "Life" en 1993.
C'est de la science complexe, mais ce n'est pas extrêmement complexe.
Tout ce dont on a besoin pour créer une atmosphère sur Mars,
et pour rendre Mars habitable, est probablement là-bas.
Et on a juste à envoyer là-bas de petites usines nucléaires
qui absorbent l'oxyde de fer à la surface de Mars et recrachent de l'oxygène.
Le problème est que cela prend 300 ans pour terraformer Mars, au minimum.
Disons 500 ans pour faire ça correctement.
Il n'y a pas de raison de ne pas commencer dès maintenant. (Rires)
Numéro 3 -- n'est-ce pas génial ? (Rires)
Une nouvelle épidémie mondiale. Les gens font la guerre aux germes
depuis toujours,
et de temps en temps les germes prennent le dessus.
En 1918, on a eu une épidémie de grippe aux États-Unis qui a tué 20 millions de personnes.
A l'époque, la population était de 100 millions.
La fièvre bubonique en Europe, au Moyen-Âge,
a tué 1 européen sur 4.
Le SIDA revient; Ebola semble repointer son nez
beaucoup trop fréquemment,
et de vieilles maladies comme le choléra deviennent résistantes aux antibiotiques.
Nous savons tous le genre de panique qui peut survenir
quand de vieilles maladies refont surface, comme l'anthrax.
La pire chose est qu'un germe simple, comme le staphylocoque,
pour lequel nous avons un antibiotique qui fonctionne encore, mute.
Et nous savons que la staphylocoque peut faire des choses incroyables.
Une cellule de staphylocoque en contact avec une cellule musculaire peut lui emprunter des gènes,
quand les antibiotiques arrivent, et changer et muter.
Le danger est que quelques germes comme le staphylocoque puissent --
puissent muter en quelque chose de très virulent, très contagieux,
et se répandre dans la population avant qu'on ne puisse faire quoi que ce soit.
C'est déjà arrivé. Il y a 12 000 ans,
il y a eu une vague massive d'extinctions de mammifères en Amérique,
et on suppose que c'est lié à un virus.
Que pouvons-nous faire ?
C'est dingue. On donne des antibiotiques (Applaudissements)
chaque vache, chaque mouton, chaque poulet, reçoit des antibiotiques chaque jour,
tous -- vous savez, vous allez au restaurant, vous mangez du poisson, j'en ai une bonne pour vous,
tout est d'élevage. Vous savez, vous devriez demander quand vous allez au restaurant si c'est du poisson sauvage,
parce qu'ils ne vous le diront pas. Nous dévoilons le code --
c'est comme à la guerre, et donner à quelqu'un votre code secret.
Nous donnons aux germes les moyens de nous battre.
On doit régler ça. On doit bannir ça tout de suite.
Deuxièmement, notre système de santé public, comme on l'a vu avec l'anthrax, est un vrai désastre.
Nous avons une grosse augmentation de maladies aux États-Unis,
nous ne sommes pas préparés à l'affronter.
Il y a de l'argent dans le budget fédéral, l'année prochaine,
pour construire un service de santé publique.
Mais je ne pense pas que ce soit vraiment nécessaire.
Numéro 2 -- mon préféré -- on croise un trou noir vicieux.
Vous savez, il y a 10 ans -- ou 15 ans, vraiment --
vous alliez à une convention d'astronomie et vous disiez,
"Vous savez, il y a probablement un trou noir au centre de chaque galaxie."
et ils vous viraient de la scène.
Et aujourd'hui, si vous allez à une de ces conventions et que vous dîtes,
"Eh bien, je ne pense pas qu'il y ait des trous noirs là-haut", ils vous vireraient de la scène.
Notre compréhension du fonctionnement de l'univers est vraiment --
a progressé incroyablement ces dernières années.
Nous pensons qu'il y a 10 millions d'étoiles mortes rien que dans la Voie Lactée -- notre galaxie.
Et ces étoiles se sont comprimées jusque 20 ou 25 km de large,
et ce sont des trous noirs. Et ils absorbent tout autour d'eux,
même la lumière, c'est pourquoi on ne peut les voir.
La plupart devrait être en orbite autour de quelque chose.
Mais les galaxies sont des lieux très violents et des choses peuvent être détachées de leur orbite.
Aussi l'espace est-il incroyablement vaste.
Donc même si vous envoyez un million de ces choses hors de leur orbite
les chances pour qu'on en rencontre une sont très minces.
Mais -- il n'a besoin d'être proche que d'environ 1,5 milliards de km.
A 1,5 milliards de km, voici ce qui se passe pour l'orbite terrestre --
elle devient elliptique au lieu de circulaire.
Et pendant trois mois par an,
les températures en surface montent à 150°F ou 180°F (65°C ou 80°C);
pendant 3 mois par an, elles descendent à -50°F (-45°C).
Ça n'ira pas trop bien. Que pouvons nous faire ?
Et c'est mon plus effroyable -- (Rires)
je n'ai pas de bonne réponse pour celle-ci.
Encore, nous devons envisager devenir des colonisateurs.
Et finalement, numéro 1 -- le plus grand danger que nous connaissons, je pense,
un très gros astéroïde se dirige vers la Terre.
La chose importante à noter -- ce n'est pas une question de si,
c'est une question de quand, et quelle taille.
En 1908, une comète de seulement 60 mètres
a explosé en Sibérie et a rasé les forêts sur 160 km.
Ça a eu l'effet d'environ 1000 bombes de Hiroshima.
Les astronomes estiment que des petits astéroïdes comme celui-ci viennent à peu près tous les 100 ans.
En 1989, un gros astéroïde est passé à 600 000 km de la Terre.
Rien de grave, vrai ?
Il est passé au travers de l'orbite terrestre. Nous étions à cet endroit six heures plus tôt.
Un petit astéroïde, disons 1 km de large, causerait des tempêtes de feu
suivi par un grave refroidissement climatique dû aux débris projetés --
l'hiver nucléaire de Carl Sagan --
un astéroïde de 8 km de large provoquerait des extinctions majeures --
nous pensons que celui qui a eu les dinosaures faisait 8 km de large.
Où se trouvent-ils ? Il y a quelque chose nommé la ceinture de Kuiper,
qui -- quelques personnes pensent que Pluton n'est pas une planète,
c'est là que se trouve Pluton, dans la ceinture de Kuiper.
Il y a aussi quelque chose un peu plus loin appelé le nuage d'Oort.
Il y a environ 100 000 boules de glace et de pierre -- des comètes --
là-haut, qui font 80 km de diamètre et plus,
et elles font régulièrement un petit tour
en direction du soleil et passent relativement proche de nous.
Plus inquiétant, je pense, sont les astéroïdes qui se trouvent entre Mars et Jupiter.
Les gens du Sloan Digital Sky Survey nous ont dit l'automne dernier --
ils réalisent la première carte de l'univers -- une carte en trois dimensions,
qu'il y a probablement 700 000 astéroïdes entre Mars et Jupiter
qui font 1 km ou plus.
Donc vous dites, bon, quelles sont vraiment les chances que ça arrive ?
Andrew, peux-tu nous montrer le diagramme ?
C'est le graph que le Dr. Clark Chapman du Southwestern Research Institute
a présenté au Congrès il y a quelques années.
Vous noterez que les chances qu'un impact d'astéroïde/comète vous tue
sont d'environ 1 pour 20 000, selon leurs travaux.
Maintenant, regardez celui juste en dessous.
Crash d'avion, 1 pour 20 000.
Nous dépensons énormément d'argent à éviter de mourir d'un accident d'avion,
et nous ne dépensons pratiquement rien pour ça. Et encore, on peut complètement l'éviter.
Nous avons finalement trouvé, l'année dernière, la technologie pour arrêter cela.
Pouvons nous avoir les solutions ?
La NASA dépense 3 millions de dollars chaque année -- 3 millions --
c'est de l'argent de poche -- pour rechercher les astéroïdes.
Car nous pouvons vraiment trouver chaque astéroïde qui est là-haut,
et s'il peut frapper la Terre, et quand il peut frapper la Terre.
Et ils essaient de les trouver.
Mais ça va prendre 10 ans, en dépensant 3 millions par an,
et même là, ils disent qu'ils ne pourront cataloguer que 80% d'entre eux.
Pour les comètes, c'est encore plus compliqué.
Nous n'avons pas la technologie pour prédire la trajectoire des comètes,
ou quand l'une que nous avons nommé pourrait arriver.
Mais nous aurions beaucoup de temps, si nous les voyons arriver.
Nous avons vraiment besoin d'un observatoire dédié.
Vous noterez que beaucoup de comètes portent le nom de personnes dont on n'entend jamais parler --
des astronomes amateurs ? C'est parce que personne ne les recherche, sauf les amateurs.
Nous avons besoin d'un observatoire dédié qui recherche les comètes.
Deuxième partie de la solution -- nous devons trouver un moyen d'exploser un astéroïde,
ou de changer sa trajectoire. Il y a un an, on a fait une chose étonnante.
On a envoyé une sonde vers cette ceinture d'astéroïdes,
appelée NEAR, Near Earth Asteroid Rendezvous.
Et ces gens se sont mis en orbite autour d'un astéroïde de 45 -- ou non, 33 km, appelé Eros.
Et alors bien sûr, ils ont envoyé une de ces choses de la NASA
où ils avaient des suppléments de batteries et de carburant et tout ça,
et alors tout à la fin, ils ont atterri --
quand la mission était terminée, ils ont vraiment atterri sur cette chose.
Nous avons posé une sonde sur un astéroïde. C'est pas grand chose.
Maintenant, le problème d'envoyer une bombe pour cette chose,
est qu'il n'y a rien sur lequel s'appuyer dans l'espace, car il n'y a pas d'air.
Une explosion nucléaire est juste chaude,
mais nous n'avons rien d'assez gros pour faire fondre un astéroïde de 33 km.
Ou pour le vaporiser, ça serait mieux.
Mais nous pouvons apprendre à atterrir sur ces astéroïdes qui portent nos noms
et y mettre un truc comme un petit moteur à propulsion ionique,
qui pourrait doucement, lentement, après quelque temps, le pousser dans une trajectoire différente,
qui, si nos calculs sont exacts, éviterait de frapper la Terre.
C'est juste un problème de les trouver, d'y aller, et de faire quelque chose.
Je sais que votre tête tourne avec tout ceci.
Waouu ! Tant de menaces !
La chose, je pense, à se souvenir, est le 11 Septembre.
On ne veut pas se retrouver mal préparé, encore une fois.
Nous savons ces choses.
La science a le pouvoir de prédire le futur dans beaucoup de cas.
La connaissance est la force.
La pire chose à faire est de dire, mon Dieu, j'ai suffisamment de préoccupations
pour m'occuper de la menace des astéroïdes.
C'est une erreur qui pourrait littéralement nous coûter notre futur.
Merci.